(suspenseful music)
- [Presenter] The Loch Ness Monster
is one of our most enduring myths.
People have sought its
secrets for over 1,500 years
but only one man has
devoted his entire life
to learning the truth.
Alone, in a van.
By the loch.
And no, he's not a wacko,
it's just his thing.
(playful instrumental music)
- My name's Steve Feltham,
and for the last 25 years
I've been a full-time hunter
of the Loch Ness Monster.
I first came to Loch Ness when
I was a seven-year-old boy
and found this set of
caravans with this gang
of grown men hunting for
monsters in Loch Ness.
And I thought, that's amazing.
That would be the life for
me, I'd love to do that!
- [Presenter] And so he did.
Twenty five years ago he quit
his job, sold his house,
bought this van, and pursued his passion.
He now holds the Guinness Record
for the longest continuous
search at Loch Ness.
- In all my time here I've only seen one
possible sighting of something.
All you saw was a spray of water
off of the back of something,
boff, boff, boff, boff, boff,
like a torpedo shooting through.
To this day that remains a mystery to me
as to what that was.
That was in the first year of being here
and I thought, right, this
job's gonna be really easy.
That's one sighting.
25 years later I'm still sat here waiting
for that second sighting.
Some people think it's giant eels,
some people think there's a rip in time.
Others believe there's a spaceship
on the bottom of the loch.
It's more likely to turn
out to be big catfish
than a spaceship on
the bottom of the loch.
The reason I sit here and I
try and solve this mystery
is because that's what
makes my heart sing.
People say, "Is it lifestyle
or is it the mystery?"
It's both.
My life contains freedom,
adventure, unpredictability,
and the chance of one of the
world's greatest discoveries,
should I ever happen to find Nessie.
It's a dream come true.
If that little
seven-year-old boy could see
what became of him, he
wouldn't believe his luck.